welcome everybody to not just the
greatest show which I will say I'll put
that forth without any hesitation but to
the greatest episode of the greatest
show where peak peak peak peak because
today we have an exclusive about none
other than the most reoccurring villain
and the EH the universal so Flo Antonio
we have uncovered evidence this is a h3
exclusive through an anonymous tipster
that so Flo is running an n95 I mean can
I call it a scam Dan I mean legal
purposes maybe not but but what I've
uncovered is that so Flo is selling he's
selling or he was selling he sold
thousands and thousands of n95 masks
that were never shipped via a what's a
word for something where you sell it but
then you never ship it and you never had
it to begin with what do you call that
oh yeah I forget the word yeah but but
we have an anonymous tip from someone
who was working with him on that project
but then they gave us a ton of leads and
we were able to basically verify a lot
of the information and evidence he
presented to us via our own
investigation so I'm very excited to dig
into what can only be called the
greatest h3 exclusive all-time Wow
but before we get down hill from here
spicy today's episode is sponsored by
Adam and Eve neon DS and honey and I
will say I gotta follow up first of all
with Papa John was on our show last week
for a call it and he had graciously
offered to donate $100,000 to our help
campaign we're giving away $100,000 of
our own money on Twitter for a hundred
days and he aggressively offered to
augment that unfortunately after talking
to my accountant she's like look dude
you're not a you're not a you're not a
nonprofit this is just gonna this is
gonna turn it to a whole mess
and so she advised against taking his
money which probably soap so what what
he's decided to do in lieu of that is to
donate a hundred thousand dollars to the
LA Regional Food Bank in our name so a
hundred thousand dollars is going to the
food bank the most reputable food bank
here in Los Angeles and that should help
feed what'd you say dad four hundred
thousand meals cuz you talk yeah it's
like an absurd amount I forget the exact
conversion but they say you know every
ten dollars does like four meals or
something like that so you did you know
you multiply that a lot so that's a lot
of food that's amazing so I thank Papa
John for donating in our name to that I
like food bank
thank mind that will go to help a lot of
people yeah and that should satisfy that
should satisfy people who said I should
have donated to the food bank so that's
awesome now I was something just threw
me for a loop this morning Elon Musk has
been losing his ass on Twitter lately
why is going on and I was like man I got
talked about this ELA cuz Iran's a
subject of many conversations here on
the podcast I'm a fan of Elon Musk and
everything he's achieved but he's been
going on for he's been going on like
anti lockdown rants on Twitter saying
free America I'm opening his Twitter he
pinned it he said free America now okay
he's been just tweeting all kinds of
media about how the lockdown is
unwarranted and that the death rate is
way lower than we think
and I have to say based on what I
understand again I'm not gonna profess
to be as smart as Elon Musk but I have
looked and read a lot about the corona
virus as you guys know and as I
understand it it's a lot of dubious
science these suggestions that the
lockdown is unnecessary and that the
death rate is low and that we don't care
if all people die and all this it's very
dubious and from from what I understand
especially from our conversation with
dr. King is that
if you open up the economy and just let
everyone do their thing the economy's
gonna cause mm-hmm this is not it's
counterproductive
anyway he tweeted out today and what
could only be perceived as a drug-fueled
rant and I'm telling you [ __ ] he says
classifying all deaths as Corona
even if Corona didn't cause the death is
simply a lie and well I guess we I don't
think that's what's happening I think
the actual truth is that the corona
death deaths are even higher than what's
being reported because there's a lot of
people dying at home who who are not
going to the hospital right and so and
so again this was somewhat dubious
misinformation he actually tweeted out a
video that was removed by YouTube for
misinformation so that's pretty epic so
anyway he tweeted out today I am selling
all of my physical possessions will not
will no longer own a house how is that
related well we I don't you never know
if he's memeing or not cuz apparently
he's like I should post her no that's
like this thing and then he says and
then this was the best when he goes
Tesla stock price is too high in my
opinion which means he's shorting his
own company and his stock of Tesla
immediately tanked ten percent actually
now it's at ten point three percent
that's incredible he talked he take this
old company stock by 10 percent there's
people in the comments like you know I
just lost ten thousand dollars you know
what while that is hilarious I don't we
don't necessarily know that he has
actually shorted his own right right
right
like that would obviously be highly
illegal and probably send him to jail so
no he didn't sure he didn't sure I'm
sure he did what I mean is he's tanking
his own stock sure yeah yeah that he
starts singing the star-spangled banner
he says oh say does that star-spangled
Spangled Banner yet wave gave proof
through the night that our flag was
still there and the Rockets red glare
the bombs bursting in air now give the
people back their freedom
isn't that great he's like I sang the
star-spangled banner
now give the people hook to freedom he
also said that his girlfriend is mad at
him right here he says my girlfriend
Grimes is mad at me and their response
was someone said well that's good news
to hear that you're still together and
then he said baby due on Monday
so I think he's gotta be he's on
something man there's no explanation I
mean thinking back to when we were a few
days before our due dates yeah if you
were tweeting this kind of madness I
would have had a heart attack he was a
no space to be I can't imagine
well no and and well thank you and no of
course I wouldn't I would just cause a
bunch of drama when you're in Israel
while your dad was yes thank you for the
ice but but anyway I was just shocked I
mean most of all just that he said his
who says it's my company is overvalued
and and then the investors like all
right cool
no fascinating stuff I would follow Elon
Musk's there's a there's a whole thing
going on here so there you have it
Elon Musk ladies and gentlemen shave 10%
off his stock in an hour before we get
into the so flow there's a lot of stuff
I want to catch up on to Invader V is a
twitch streamer who wasn't a bit of
controversy for what can only be
described as a very epic rant of shaming
her audience into subbing which is
pretty I mean it's amazing here let's
watch invader V is she popular do you
guys know or is she like a small
streamer oh no there's a lot more
attention now after this
dude the twitch link is down I'm glad we
we have a mirror yeah I'm glad we have
the mirror so here it is because I'm not
asking you for a large financial
contribution if it costs $20 to son $20
is quite a bit of money $20 is but a sub
is $5 at maximum in whatever your
currency is it's maybe $10 and it
doesn't matter how broke you are if you
have time to watch Tom long you have $5
is kind of a lot but when I was 12 $5
was like I mean a [ __ ] that was a
Subway sandwich I'm not I wasn't
spending twin dollars you know meal and
I was bro that's like a mega splurge
when you drop 20 bucks on a meal damn
I'm just saying that I'm on a dollar
doesn't change in different currencies
it stays five dollars what did she say
well she's like in whatever I do
currency it's like ten dollars oh yeah
but five dollars I'm like anyway five
dollars that's a lot of money dude if
she was saying one dollar maybe I could
find easily what you mean to say is I'm
so irresponsible with my money I can't
support the entertainment that I enjoy
dude she's got like this is psycho I
gotta say she's like man we got to get
this girl selling some timeshares or
something I was like wow this is a hard
sell for a twitch twitch sucks man holy
[ __ ]
she'll be a good mom someday
she's got this like evil laugh right and
just in general I wonder if the people
who follow her are just into this kind
of like being mean yes I had the same
dog it's total like femdom yeah it's
total femdom
it's I've seen other oven diesels into
that Vin Diesel what do you think about
invader by you wants her to step on his
dick alright I just reminded me I saw
this one video on what's that one
website words got like all or if you
[ __ ] this girl wanna stilettos steps
on the deck in the kind of spike on the
stiletto goes through the deck like I
never went back to that site but I I
think you're right I think it is some
kind of femdom that they like being
demeaned she goes on because I was like
interesting so anyway this clip was
going around everyone was making fun of
her and I was starting I was digging
into her clips there's a lot of great
stuff from her she's a character in so
she's reading a comic some guy part of
this she goes I'm unemployed I can't I
don't have any money
so here's her response it's five dollars
it's really like you're never you're not
gonna you're no one's gonna convince me
that what I'm saying is so rude or so
unacceptable or so outrageous something
cold as hell man she's got yeah that's
not a sane man oof [ __ ] she'll be a
great mom someday I definitely could not
afford to pay for a tweet subscription
when we were poor it's just not on the
top priority they send down relationship
then you can find five dollars she's
right I mean you just starve if you need
to
you're watching this stream if your life
if you were sucked
I mean she's right right if your life is
so destitute that you're watching this
stream and your endless femdom
relationship you need to pony up for her
you got a pony up first no matter what
now I couldn't afford to give to her one
point at the time but I was I was um I
wasn't consuming her high-quality
content I was wondering if she's like in
like 2021 kind of thing where she's too
young to understand what she's saying
kind of thing she seems smart actually
is 29 she's 29 you looked up her age
yeah she looked 29 yeah well according
to Google Google's never wrong I like 29
oh so she's got a little bit what do you
call that an anime we're like the old
lady looks young lolly al-ahli right is
that what it is
there's this thing in anime where and
you can correct me and they have this
thing where you have like an old lady
but that she looks like she's 12
so that you can like section so it's
like weird pedo [ __ ] but you can
sexualize this little animal right
colonel being that's actually 900 years
old exactly matter that she looks like a
child that's what you know too much
about it I just heard it's called a
lolly right dan dan said is not I mean I
guess that's the term for yeah I mean
somebody look up the alley
I guess define it somebody look up love
it and I want that definition I guess
FBI is gonna kick in my door
somebody divine lolly god damn is it
that bad Japanese media focusing on
attraction to young girls yeah oh yeah
same thing
oh wait that's lolly Kahn yeah I guess
lolly is a shorthand for it or something
I don't know okay that was a bit much
yeah I by the way have not looked at
that beulah I've heard no ice also were
talking about on Twitter I thought it
was just about old people look young not
like about specifically about young
anime girls that's creepy as far I could
but she is a look
she's Jesus great we're at a time for a
sponsor read I don't know if a sponsor
he wants to come right after the Lalique
on so let me let me let me move on away
from the lolly I didn't endorse the
lolly by the way I'm just saying it's a
thing lollipop lollipop Oh lolli
lollipop how long we've been going down
she she later apologized for her remarks
oh she erased over endorse it I don't I
mean how bad is that to say I wonder if
she's another daddy Dom shed no I think
she's the dog no she's the dog what what
are they what do you guys call her do
they call her mommy is that weird but
maybe mommy Dom mommy thumbs awesome if
I get in a diaper and you like put [ __ ]
up my ass
I don't know what it I don't know what
it is honey honey honey you go that
honey is the free online shopping tool
that automatically finds the best promo
codes and applies them to your cart a
but do you know how great it feels to
save and what about how it feels to save
with honey well let me tell you saving
with honey
feels like sliding into a seat on the
train just before the doors close and
there's an old person
watching and you're like I'm not getting
up for them you know what I mean I know
when there's a whole person on the bus
or train you like I [ __ ] them it's my
seat and then and then hitting every
green light on your commute that's how
good it feels
finishing up your podcast episode right
as you walk into work it's that perfect
timing that perfect fit hmm that's what
it is all about with honey honey is that
perfect no wipe or one wipe [ __ ] you got
a chip wipe wants to check that's how
good it feels to save with honey let me
tell you what I did with honey Papa
John's Pizza that we ordered the other
week and honor of Papa John himself
saved $11.64 without even knowing we
were doing it here's how it works you
just buy the thing you're at the
checkout you've got this plugin
installed it's just you install it in a
matter of two clicks by going to join
honey calm slash h3 when you're at your
car and you're checking out honey's like
hold on let me just check the internet
automatically for codes and it's like
boom just what was that sound so honey
goes ah I found the coupon boss I just
saved you $11.64 on your pizza pie I'm
like dude that's sick I'm about to pay
full price it's just like that that's
how it works it's found it's 18 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings we've got over 30,000 stores
online including Macy's targets for at
Best Buy and more threatening and
they're adding more every day users love
honey that's why it has a hundred
thousand five star reviews on the google
chrome store using honey feels pretty
great it's a daily victory plus it's
free to use and install just a few
seconds get honey for free at join
honeycomb / HP that's join honey calm /
h3 cut back to the apology hi
and you're very angry about what I said
in that clip I'm very angry I'm not that
angry she went from like femdom to uh
interviewing or like week 1950 secretary
like secretary from admin her posture
and [ __ ] I would prefer if she just got
out the femdom look like weapons just
started cracking unfold the clip that
you saw does not represent my true
feelings hmm I've streamed for hundreds
of hours and I've said support
communities after you support yourself
first it's only five dollars
I think this clip ever went like mega
viral I think like pewdiepie I thought
everyone thought was talking about it
it's intense when you go from being like
having a couple hundred people watching
you to like everybody on the internet
like a literal tsunami of hate can make
anybody crumble even this fandom I do
have to say I checked out her Instagram
you did yeah I did it well I don't
research hold on I want to pull it up
all the comments are so awful oh my god
yeah yeah she's getting hard do you
remember any here let me look at her mo
I can't look at it um when you guys
pulled up and read some to us yeah I
just pulled up her most recent Oh ash
look at this
she has 43 thousand followers and her
most recent post has almost 2,000
comments so that's already so this is
something it's just everybody's just
spamming clown emoji time for you to get
off that entitled ass and get a real job
Wow I mean I have to say like
lmao you're literally 20 29 years old
get a real job you [ __ ] granny it's
crazy what are you what are you doing
posting on insta you should be working
well she's I mean I hate to say it but
she basically said the same thing to her
fans alright but do you feel bad for at
any point when this harassment continues
for doesn't even call harassment because
she kind of brought it on herself
obviously but at what point do you feel
bad for her I I mean this Instagram post
was from like a month ago but the
comments are still there's comments from
34 minutes ago an hour ago it's like
people are just like this video went
viral it was like two weeks ago at a
certain point it's like this it's really
not that important guys so there's
there's like a small group of dedicated
men I'm assuming men angry men who are
beat some women but yeah probably men
it's probably a safe assumption yeah I
don't know I just can't help but have a
little bit of PTSD because just from
anytime that we are but what she said
she'll be fine you know yeah she'll be
fine it was it was pretty good I mean
like it kind of should have gone viral
cuz you know on Twitter is always this
culture of like people begging for subs
is always a like a soft yeah she did
like the ultimate begging for soap yeah
[Music]
but then so I went down her clip pole
went on the clip Pole I saw this clip
recently I was like wow this girl's
crazy and then I realized just now it
was her it was her alright I did see
that one randomly on somewhere so watch
this
every one of you can have both hands on
the keyboard she says she says both
hands on the keyboard because she often
acknowledges that people are probably
masturbating there she goes I bet with
some of you handle that means they're
fully engaged with the mean to me I'm
sure I mean no it's probably most people
with hands on the keyboard but I'm not
wearing it's going to yeah the planet is
dying the government hates us the
animals are leaving the aliens aren't
contacting us we might be alone it just
might be you and me but that's okay
because its own so obviously she has to
be on drugs right can you deliver speech
like that sober I mean not necessarily
I'd have to see the context
she's right I'll take a little of that
whatever pass that room today to what
people do for drugs these days but do
you think it changed that much I don't
think it changed that much I don't know
man dosing of acid as well that's what
yeah I don't know anything about you
just take a little bit of acid like
every day yeah apparently you just take
a tiny bit and then you just feel it a
little bit and it's supposed like a
parent apparently people in Silicon
Valley like Megatech billionaires all do
micro things weird thing I mean at a
certain point when you have a family and
kids you kind of got to put that [ __ ]
behind you I feel like you can't come
home you have microdose daddy he's
microdose I think that it's such a small
I don't actually know I've never I've
never micro dosed I've seen someone
doing it and they were they were high
for sure but maybe he didn't maybe maybe
it wasn't so much he's like I'm like
reducing bro I was like your [ __ ]
medium dosing yeah impressive frankly I
have to say I was impressed by that on
par with them with what's-his-name did
that this is this is BA I don't know the
name I don't know the movie what kind of
now Jesus anything great commentary this
is what we subscribe for Glenn the movie
about the church yes Glenn Gary Ross
he's famous what's his name the famous
actor
Noel Pacino Alec Baldwin thank you yes
about the watch it's like that ABC
always be closing always be closing
always be camp from The Bachelor this is
a mess can always be can possibly follow
this conversation
sidenote bachelor listen to your heart
is amazing
it's so good cuz it's like bachelor
amplified times tent because all these
people are want to be musicians and
they're so vain and they're so desperate
because they're like musicians and all
the guys are walking around with guitars
are judged on their music performance
and their love at the same time which
makes no sense but right it's great
is it is it actually good because yes
yeah watch that [ __ ] I didn't watch
the whole season I'd watch the finale
the two-part for now that was divorcees
in about that last season was the worst
season no no no no no I stopped
I'm telling you Dan that was the worst
season a bachelor of all time I couldn't
even make it through it dan I promise if
you put on listen to your heart you were
gonna you were gonna love it it's so
compelling but we really talked about
great shows I'm not gonna mention 90-day
fiance
dude we're having such a tangent I'm in
the middle of a segment I had a couple
more Clips over I wanna let's just let's
just say this 90-day fiance before the
nine days is the best sit-in of reality
television
I've ever seen in my life the greatest
show right now dude you've got big an
you they by the way everyone knows Big
Ed he's not even the best side story
there's a one guy who has been dating
this Ukrainian girl for seven years he
flies to Ukraine to meet her he doesn't
even have her phone number he's only
talked to her on this chat and he said
in case to chance paid $100,000 over
seven years he considers his girlfriend
and he can sheesh and she blows him off
and then he goes on a loss journey to
some war-torn Ukrainian city on the edge
of war with Russia looking for her
walking around the small ukrainian
village thing to know this girl it's
unbelievable another one there's this
older woman and by the way this woman
and that guy are both from Las Vegas and
if she goes she goes I'm dating this guy
named Williams it's not a name Williams
it's William with the acid in it sniper
man and it's like some mega jacked
dude who looks like something like you
would have a million followers on
Instagram but yet somehow you only is
like a hundred followers on Instagram so
she's flirting with this guy sending him
nudes and then all the sudden his
profile disappears all there it's
disappeared and then she gets an email
from somebody that says hey I'm gonna
release your nudes and come harm you
because I have your address unless you
pay me she goes there's a woman who got
scammed by some Nigerian with her nudes
it's all on the show she's gotta talk to
her daughter she's like I and she's so
delusional she goes I still believe that
he's real and her daughter's like I told
you who's scamming you from the very
beginning we all knew their daughters
his pictures and and she's like what is
wrong with you and then she's like yeah
and I sent him pictures that now he is
trying to get money for and the
daughters like what kind of pictures
like don't tell me you sent him a nudes
I'll tell you everything and like Big Ed
is amazing but these other two side
stories are even crazier it's the I love
when that David what this is named David
he was sitting in the coffee shop and he
waited for her for like three hours and
he had like the flowers yeah he was
drinking a bottle of champagne by
himself and the small ukrainian village
well they here's the other part about
this guy here's the other part about
this guy this Ukrainian girl he had gone
there to meet her several years before
and she stood him up yeah okay
think about that and then three years
later he went back again he's going
again and he got stood up again every
time he talks about murder he says my
girlfriend anyway you gotta watch yo you
gotta watch it you gotta watch it
they only chat over this website he'd
spent like a hundred grand talking the
other week about that with the whole
idubbbz thing about people not
understanding simple misusing it and all
this stuff
that's a [ __ ] simp textbook and he's
70 years old and has this really awful
yeah
and then he so he goes man I'm just I'm
so disappointed she stood me up again
and then by the way they could only chat
on the site if they're both online at
the same time so he has no way to
contact her he can't even message her
he'd they have to be online at the same
time or they can't chat and so he
finally gets the opportunity to chat
with her and she goes oh she says after
all this as she goes hi would you like
to meet up for pictures and to to
continue our relationship because I the
green card or the green card
that's it like so inhuman and then he
goes you think he's gonna be pissed
right but he goes it's amazing
what about any pull is a skip Ian ended
change his shirt in the restaurant yeah
yeah he yep he was giving himself a
shower and the restaurant he brought a
change of shirts because it was too
sweaty want to look his best as a wig
right anyway we were talking about
invader beat I have we got to do ads
we're like way over now wait what after
that tangent oh we didn't ever did it me
Andy sorry it's officially spring which
means it's officially spring cleaning
time yes that's the thing if you're not
doing it you should spring cleaning
especially with your underwear drawer I
have to agree you really want to empty
your end underwear drawer there I have
underwear that's so old that the like
the band gets crusty from age any like
loses all elasticity you guys know what
I'm talking about your red underwear
that all relationships toxic all
tattered undies move on to a membership
with the softness underwears to ever
grace your nether regions a fresh start
for spring why do you need me on DS
membership you ask honestly because it's
fun it's an easy way to give your future
self a present each month membership
with communities is full of perks like
site-wide savings early access free
shipping and new ridiculously soft
underwear delivered your door each month
building your on D collection makes your
adult life just a tad easier more undies
equals less laundry
signs what does that mean why is it less
laundry I don't know does it more on
these illegal war laundry maybe maybe
because you can you have more clean
under exactly the cycle is longer yeah
okay and I'm not gonna think too much
about it yeah science they said it's
beyond me Mandy says they're made of
micro Moke modal which is basically like
what did the what's the material in
Wakanda vibranium
it's like vibranium for underwear micro
modal what the heck is that it's a
magical sustainable softest heck fabric
made from trees yes trees that makes
your my phone just made a sound without
a mutated fabric made from trees yes
trees that makes your bits feel like
they're floating on a cloud me Andes are
offered in a range of sizes from extra
small to 4 XL mandis has a great offer
for my listeners for any first-time
purchase you get 15% off and free
shipping that's a no-brainer
especially because you have about 100
billion satisfaction guaranteed so to
get 15% off your first order free
shipping and 100% set satisfaction
guarantee go to me Andes calm /h 3
that's me on DS dot-com
/h 3 alright now it's been like an hour
and we can finally finish this segment
so this is what you got a little weird
for me okay I mean tell me what do you
think about this clip here are usually
men in relationships or actively dating
between the ages of I think 25 to maybe
42 mm-hmm I usually work in tech um a
lot of Engineers are in here right now
it's really crazy the other day when we
were talking about um like what we all
do for a living
oh no so when you guys um don't know to
me it tells me your name that is
attached to your PayPal and if your name
is attached to your PayPal and you don't
know to me
I look you up on Google
I googled and I keep your linkedin
that's over that was weird
although I guess if you're donating to
her maybe you're flattered that she
knows who you are right cuz it's all
about she's like your virtual girl yeah
I guess some people would probably like
that do you think she's you know why you
would put that out there yeah I find out
very weird but again I'm not in the ski
co system I don't know the whole thing
is very weird but clearly the people
follow her like whatever this is the way
she talks she's streaming right now I'm
curious how many people watch her see
she should be working as the middle of
the day hello
130 offline what the hell are you doing
get a job run off of twitch oh you think
so by the mob yeah I get the feeling
that she wouldn't care too much about
that I mean if she's constantly getting
brigaded by a thousand people telling
her she's I hope not I hope this doesn't
scare her off oh ish yeah if you just
search her invader V last live thirty
four minutes ago so nevermind oh good
she has a hundred and fifty two thousand
followers that's not subs that's just
followers
I wanted to see her delivery I feel like
she must be somewhat used to getting
that kind
yeah she invites it you know she
definitely invited it's which is a
hostile environment honestly
so that struck me as weird and then and
then here she is being a so this does
tell me we think about this one you and
this our final clip you would never open
your mouth again not only yourself but
your entire family and every single
member of your family who ever existed
in succession to bring you the absolute
lowest form of done on the planet all of
them are ashamed of you
he's like why just alright that's pretty
good I gotta say props to her I gotta
say I'm not I'm kind of is that like a
character that's what I'm I mean it's
that her thing
I'm sure she's playing it up you know I
gotta say I don't already hate her I'm
kind of a fan of her stick if it's a
stick I guess if it doesn't seem that
bad I mean look if you're a fan a lot
you know what you're getting yourself
into
it's like say USA you know I mean but
from the outside I think it looks like
she's having she's enjoying herself you
know anyway we're moving on we've talked
about that for much long enough sloppy
joe I should show these I've been
meaning to show these we're so close
next by the way you guys sloppy joe
biden meme album we were wondering which
one's the funniest because there's been
some really good sloppy joe memes so you
let's see which one's the best here you
took everything from me Star Wars mean
you'd I don't even know where I am
pretty good it's not that's not Star
Wars I mean it's uh Avengers
oh you're mixing your Disney scene is
this from oh this is a little Thanos
yeah and it's the the stupid redhead
chick Oh at the end I'm not gonna say
anything people are gonna hate me if I
say that I just like that thing about
this film I did the [ __ ] log ok bunch
lock but it's definitely Sherlock anyway
get in loser where where yeah this one's
really popular because he's pulls up so
smug get in loser that's pretty great
come on that's a fantastic game
no ok I just get frustrated by all of
these cuz it's still just insane that
they're running this man yeah well what
option is there look he got it he got it
I mean what do you I mean you know let's
roll the dice baby let's play this play
who wants to be a president who wouldn't
want to vote for that man how do I open
a PDF learn more it's pretty good Joe
2020 you know the thing Oh what is this
the Virgin Joe Biden first the Chad corn
pop oh is that from a story yeah that's
the guy that he he threatened to beat up
when he was a teenager and he likes to
tell that story I'm gonna skip this
because there's too much text group no
Biden I'm Joe Biden and I forgot this
message pretty good confuses wipe with
steps with his sister Biden wins Alabama
well that's pretty funny the joke being
that they like incest I'm assuming DNC
me Joe Biden 2020 man I have to say
there's there he has a lot of images of
him being really close to these girls
like little girls on on stage yeah I
don't know if you read it office Oh like
daughters and [ __ ] I actually can't tell
what she's but like people's daughters
he's always going like yeah no he's just
saying but I really don't find it like
it's some old just old man [ __ ] yeah I
don't find like Jeff Epstein gonna it's
just right just old old man yeah maybe
they said Hillary was the only candidate
that could lose to Trump but I didn't
hold my you know the thing he did say
that
hold my you know the thing we have to do
at least several things one we have to
depend on what the president's gonna do
right now and first of all he has to
wait till the cases before anything
happens look the hole that he always
does that look the whole idea is he's
got to get in place things that were
sort shortages of dam that didn't make
any sense you were supposed to
destroy the malarkey not buzzed it
that's I mean these are good moves as
far as me albums go I'm into it yeah and
then this one was this one was right
from you Dan you said he announced a
podcast preview that was so bizarre you
thought it was a parody and I agree it
was really bizarre Oh what I just closed
everything on my computer
epic my dude I really don't know but
give me one sec I'll reopen it freaking
epic so he posted on Twitter a preview
for podcast and the clip he chose to
preview his podcast podcast by the way
is named here's the deal oh that's like
what's so [ __ ] funny to me number one
yeah and he always counts you okay so
here we go
so this is what he goes yo here's my new
podcast here's the preview okay
[Laughter]
they're small like and sneakin you can
buy little packs of them and I get them
on the planes when I fly back and forth
and but the thing that is the thing that
everybody makes fun of me that when in
doubt I have a peanut butter jelly
sandwich but I learned everybody was
making fun of that and I found out John
Kerry has the same addiction peanut
butter Joey I was the best 45 seconds
tick away from that podcast to to
preview I agree that's a hell of a way
let's go here any was for the entire Wow
so you get tuned into Joe Biden's
podcast here's the deal for more
insightful nuggets like that and I and I
sneak my and I sneak the fig No
alright shall we get to the main story
here I I guess technically you wanted to
do the last ad right now another ad Dan
another ad this episode is brought to
you by Adam and Eve the number one adult
fun store Adam and Eve says the best
part of staying at home is playing at
home ela got it just so you know they've
got toys for men toys for women toys for
couples and every kind of Lube and
lotion a man or woman could dream to
shove in one of their orifices all
around the outside of an orifice we like
liquids right lingerie and so many other
fun spicy gifts take advantage of the
downtime and choose almost any item and
get 50% off at Adam and Eve com 50% off
when you do you'll get 10 free boredom
busting gifts bust you got a bus from
these blessed from the boredom busting
gifts it cludes 6 spicy movies 3 piece
bonus kit and best of all free shipping
delivered discreetly right to your door
just remember to use offer code Age 3
that's h3 at the checkout for this
amazing deal Adam and Eve has thousands
of products to make you glad you're
staying at home and busting all over
these boredom busting gifts I'm gonna
bust I'm busting with excitement adult
toys make being at home so enjoyable
in fact shopping from home is more
enjoyable when you're shopping for spicy
adult toys and you're gonna be busting
all over the place go to Adam Eve calm
and use that offer code h3 to get 50%
off just about any item plus 10 free
gifts so go to Adam and Eve and use the
code h3 at checkout when a dude finishes
you call it busting what do you what's
the word for one of women finishes do
they also bust does anyone have any
insight on that I've never brought a
woman to climax oh I don't know
fair enough I always use a term creaming
you that's disgusting exact framing
creaming do you really use that ie job
to use that from time to time now so let
me ask you if you've had sex with your
girlfriend you say and you say did you
cream yet no I won't say it in like I
won't say it in that setting I feel like
you did in a word use it in a sentence
uh man she creamed her panties oh yeah
it's just in that variable that's like
the only time that it's appropriate
though for whatever reason they get out
of the phrase cream your panties all of
a sudden it gets kind of what Duke and
cream is pants too I guess a dude creams
more than what makes more sense yeah I
think it's more of a play on that you
ever you ever cream your pants ACK
all right let's let's move on to so Flo
we've had it I've had enough bathroom
break yeah okay well we're gonna take a
quick break hard cut we'll be back to
talk about the so Flo scam I mean not a
scam but you know whatever it is when
you don't deliver stuff to people after
they bought it a legend yeah welcome
back everybody it is time for the main
story so Flo Antonio now let me start
from the top here I received an
anonymous email from somebody with
inside information onto the inner
workings of so Flo's operation and he
told me now what he told me oh I'll say
but I do I will say that we've we've
been able to independently verify a lot
of this but the numbers and stuff I
obviously have no idea if he sent any
how much he sent etc what he sent but
according to this guy so as soon as this
uh the pandemic started hitting off
there was a huge demand for n95 masks
people wanted actual medical grade masks
that could
you know filter the virus out and as you
know there's been a massive shortage of
them and therefore a very high demand
and so he accorded to him he's been
selling fake I guess I shouldn't say
fake but apparently they don't exist
according to him and 95 mass he sold
over 18,000 of them and hasn't shipped
any of them but it's been taking
people's money since February so again I
can't verify those numbers or those
facts but what I can verify I'll show
you which is the amount of complaints
and the bet is the best the Better
Business Bureau issuing a warning and
all this stuff so let me let me take you
through this so flow and 95 scheme can I
call it a scheme I don't think a scheme
is the same as a scam I would never call
it a scam I would call it a scheme an
alleged scheme let me since myself an
alleged scheme it's just a prank it's a
oh good
oh crank let's call it the n95 prank
yeah perfect
the disaster fraud prank experiment
right so his company is called Thunder
labs now I went to great lengths to make
sure that his Thunder labs is the same
as this thunder labs that was selling
these in 95 mass and not giving them to
anyone so if you look at his Instagram
bio you'll see that he's not very bright
is he
he says founder of at Thunder labs and
it says thunder lab sigh oh now he's
owned from what I can tell thunder labs
dot every extension there is and he'll
burn one of them and some kind of prank
we're gonna call it a prank and then
he'll just use a different extension so
he was he was pranking people from it
was thunder labs Co right that he was
selling these n95 masks from
well is actually Thunder shop.com okay
Thunder shockingly is a subsidiary of
the wider thunder labs Network and so
the way the kind of the best way that I
can show you that his thunder his
Thunder labs is this thunder labs shop
so here's here's the website they've
just were selling a bunch of crap or a
bunch of random crap this is what it was
and then they start selling these slick
ass mats by the way $30 for a mask that
doesn't even look protective but anyway
they say crisp and ninety-five filter
protective mask Wow
253 perfect stars that must be legit oh
yeah they had a man this Facebook is
such a [ __ ] show they had a sponsored
post on Instagram Thunder shop org slash
and 95 stay healthy this flu season with
our new carbon filter face mask can you
believe they were letting them run I
can't believe you can just run straight
up stuff like this on Facebook so here's
their website thunder laps now notice
the lightning bolt okay so if you go to
so flows if you go to so flows page and
click the Thunder labs Instagram page
you'll notice he has the same lightning
bolt it has to be it has to be his store
right it has to be it's that it's the
exact same lightning bolt and it's just
a bunch of assortment of crap so anyway
let's get into the issue here so we shop
website yeah our screenshots that you
guys were able to get before was taken
yeah was taken now on the website isn't
down yes it's like not just down it is
scrubbed from the [ __ ] Internet is
super work is pretty crazy
we had links to the wayback machine and
our document when we first researched
this but somehow the wayback machine
was scrubbed and I didn't even know you
could do that I didn't know you could do
that either I did look into it and yeah
apparently it's like a process you have
to email them like a takedown requests
bla bla bla like but there is a method
to do it and he seemingly did it because
our saved Wayback Machine links are all
dead now and if you just manually try
and search through it for any of these
thunder whatever it's just it's gone but
he but I just wonder why he would go
through all that effort and then just
keep the same logo like it's obvious I
guess he's just trying to scrub that he
was scamming people
scheming pranking people sorry not
scamming pranking people of these n95
masks but anyway it's got the same logo
we also found the Articles of
Incorporation which is public and it has
thunder labs LLC it has so Flo's name on
it he is the founding member as well as
I've sent another person with the same
last name and if you click his name you
can see other businesses he owned slaves
LLC prevent copyright LLC slay LLC
there's a [ __ ] ton of them he had a
company called prevent copyright yes so
Flo did and I'm stealing and I will say
that I'm fair well who knows best and I
will say that I'm pretty sure that all
of these companies are elaborate pranks
where they prank you out of your money
there's a ton this guy is got a shitload
of companies but basically this shop it
seems like this website that was just
selling all this super random like it's
like wish or any of those drop shipping
sites which yeah I actually when we were
researching this yesterday went back to
our old podcast with him which was like
episode like 10 or something like super
early and it was funny because part of
the conversation he was talking about
how he was getting out of the the
content gaming
getting into dropshipping and apparently
this is here we are to two and a half
years later and this let's drop [ __ ]
what does that even mean it means yeah
you know how like with Teddy fresh or or
how we used to do with our merch you
know you have an inventory and you have
a warehouse where it's all stored drop
shipping is when you you skip that
middleman you do sales and then you have
the factory send it directly to somebody
factory in China or wherever you don't
warehouse you just sell [ __ ] philia
Marvel warehouse he doesn't have any
product so I think it is from China and
sometimes you would order it and it
takes like 30 days yeah and then he
arranges to just have it sent directly
to them so he never actually has to
warehouse or store any product I don't
know if that's exactly how he was
operating the slender labs no I'm gonna
give him the benefit of the doubt and
say like maybe he thought these masks
were gonna get here from China and maybe
they never did but the fact is that
apparently he's according to this guy
and again I can't confirm that he's not
refunding people but according to the
reviews they're not nobody's gotten the
mask or the money back
here's pictures from his website they
say avoid surgical masks are you kidding
me these is that and this is like the
antiviral mask that you should be
wearing so they say don't wear this wear
this that was so weird why did they do
that well now they're saying anything is
good yeah they're like to just put a bra
on your face like that one guy so anyway
here's his [ __ ] let's see buy to get
free shipping safeguard your family from
deadly coronavirus medical grade and 95
filter mask reduces the risk of corona
virus lab tested and 95 rated I really
doubt that they've got weight it only
kills ninety five point nine nine
percent of viruses that since
shouldn't be a little higher okay so
anyway here's all the [ __ ] about how
their [ __ ] works I love how it's on like
fresh air clouds yadda yadda yadda so
that's it
he was advertising it on Instagram we
saw probably I'm sure all over Facebook
and then now we move on to the response
so here's the first link trust
Trustpilot they've got thunder shop here
73 reviews I'm surprised it even has a
half star it has one great rating and it
has 99% bad one out of five and one
person gave it a great rating I want to
read that review it was so flow
obviously oh wait the great review was
scathing hold on let me click it they
ran a Ponzi scheme that doesn't sound
great this guy gave it four stars he
says it's a Ponzi scheme it's a well-run
Ponzi scheme he says I went on their
site and it redirected to a store called
way Brooks a redirect is gone and I
ordered an item from way Brooks and
gotta actually inquired about why they
had the Thunder shop redirect to them
and they said they bought it from them
then found out the under shop ran a
Ponzi scheme of sorts so they dropped
the name
I recommend rave books though so he'll
xwy Brooks so he gave it four stars and
besides that guy it's all one stars I
wish I had read all these reviews before
these guys are criminals they collect
the money and you will never hear from
them again no response to emails you'll
never get what you bought and you will
never get your money back that's from
eight hours ago and by the way dude
these are what's crazy what's crazy is
that these aren't these are people that
don't know who he is obviously like this
is just straight-up people who got
scammed yeah
pranked zero stars item was not received
taken full payment did not respond to my
email no product no refund total scam I
ordered a dog bed oh this got person got
a dog bed they're even scamming people
on dog beds nothing for months the help
email didn't even have the right
spelling and now the website is down
yikes that's 110% scam I bought from
seeing an ad on Instagram see they
should be so ashamed I cannot believe
they're running this crazy that Facebook
allows us this company is a total joke
I'll ordered a dog bed huh so apparently
they have a whole dog bed scheme to try
to find once I order two hundred dollars
worth of masks for health care workers
in early February they took the money
yet I never received the masks and
there's no way to contact them the
website no longer exists they need to be
brought to justice
oh that sucks they need to be reported
to the authorities
I plan on contacting local news stations
to find these scam artists oh well I
know who they are so Flo today's [ __ ]
Instagram that's so Flo or you shudder I
was uh I was giving your site by
physician that cannot be true I was
given your site by a physician before
the pandemic announced and I purchased
the best mass for covet 19 there's no
way a physician recommended this I
ordered your product yet never received
the item I thought perhaps it was part
of the global need and just cannot
fulfill my order I finally saw the
charge on a credit card statement in
April yet still not receive the product
no email went on the website and it was
to see if it was in route but the
website was down that's awesome
that is so crazy I just can't believe
that I mean that's so that's really low
so there's like how much are we able to
say we're confident that it's him like
I'm just trying to think let's say let's
say let's say it possibly it's not him
well let me do the math here we know he
does this stuff just from his what he
said on our podcast we have a tipster
who said yo so Flo's doing that okay
let's set all that aside he links to
something in his profile called Thunder
labs that has the same exact logo
urban copy of this Thunder shops is the
same exact logo yep
was it thunder sharp or thunder lab shop
there's no thunder shop but the thing is
he scrubbed the Internet I'm sure he
posted all over his Facebook pages and
now he took it down cuz you can't do
this so so is there a possibility it
wasn't him yes but I mean obviously the
circumstantial evidence it would be
incredible if it wasn't him it would be
incredible incredible and then what's
also interesting is that if you look on
the Articles of Incorporation if I go
back to that you can see thunder labs
LLC was founded only nine months ago in
August of 2019 so they moved on to their
new scheme here prank if you were and
they're probably in the works of making
their next one now that this one's
burned but this really is a federal
crime and now of all times whoever is
responsible for this is really depraved
scammer who belongs in prison yes
whoever's responsible yeah right - fake
selling mass during this time that's a
you go to prison for that
and then if you go to the Better
Business Bureau you guys know the BBB
they audit businesses and give warnings
and endorsements yada yada yada
so they issued an alert for thunder labs
this was opened oh it was just opened
this month on the 12th oh so here you go
look here the Better Business Bureau
tied it together they say thunder labs
is the business and then they link to it
thunder shops org so the best but the
Better Business Bureau has connected the
dogs right and they link it to Thunder
labs at work yeah yes that's interesting
because Co was the one that we primarily
knew about but
orgas down as long as we found that ad
that said thunder labs org and again
when I did a who is on thunder labs Co
it's completely scrubbed from the
internet but the org is still around so
I think he tried to cover his tracks but
didn't do that thorough of a job and
there's still little clues hidden around
it says their website is Thunder shop
tour which is offline but if you read
the alert then you'll you'll see it's
exactly what we're talking about says
the Better Business requested competent
and reliable scientific substantial
claims for the religion for their claims
on the n95 face mask respirator they
said that in their website they claimed
that it is a and ninety five face mask
respirator certified medical grade
clinically tested and need a ninety five
rated safeguards your family from deadly
coronavirus medical grade and ninety
five filter mass reduces the risk of
khromov iris this is the ads we saw it's
definitely the same thing according to
them lab tested and clinically proven to
prevent the risk of infection yada yada
yada so they're saying you made all
these claims and they requested
scientific substantiation for those
claims did they get it so I'm going down
toward they there's so many claims
they've listing like so much it so they
said BBB Better Business Bureau notes
that the business advertised a 70% off
sale
however the timer continuously restarts
once the time expires the business also
the business also advertises a
hundred-percent money-back guarantee the
Better Business Bureau challenges these
claims based on the following codes of
advertising they link to some shed
they've basically saying that's not true
as of April ninth to the 2020 the
business has failed to respond to our
requests for substantial modifications
or discontinuation of these advertised
claims and then they have an alert at
least on one occasion BBB sent mail
- this company an attempt to develop a
report the mail was returned by the post
office therefore a complete BBB report
at this time is unavailable so they're
saying we we tried to contact their
their place of business and nobody was
there if you have information that will
assist us please speak with us might be
able to help you send them the link to
this podcast so so again this is more
evidence that this is so flows business
or at least there's definitely a lot
piling up together to support all of it
taken together yeah everything yeah
we're trying hard statement that that's
like clear evidence I don't know that so
flows the guy that was running thunder
shops and scamming people but you know
yeah so can we we should check in on so
play what's yeah he been up to so first
of all now now that I am now that we see
what he's been up to he must have made a
lot of [ __ ] minute by if if the
report is true and he sold 18,000 of
these 18 thousand times they were
expensive right like $40 $30 let's say
30 was I think it was 30 I'm eighteen
thousand I mean that's five hundred
forty thousand dollars
yeah yeah but he's got all these dog bed
schemes apparently going on as well it
sounds like his overheads pretty low
zero it's amazing when you have no
product he's mega jacked
look at this but his body I mean I don't
want a body shame the guy cuz obviously
it's great that he's in shape but I
never seen a body like that right either
like he's jacked and that's awesome but
it just don't look it's something
strange going on right like what is it
it's probably Photoshop oh you think so
yeah
Oh see I didn't even think about that
yeah that adds to looking at it oh it's
not only as a Photoshop it's really poor
that's why it looks so I'm not okay that
yeah the ABS look super messed up yeah
but I think so look at the law in the
yes coloration of its skin yeah between
the ABS and the rest oh no wonder you
okay oh it's probably trying to add like
a lot of shadow and make you know
crazy-looking yeah so bad that's awful
can also see the kind of the outline of
his package I wonder feel of for real
what I didn't notice that he would
Photoshop his package one me so anyway
we've been looking through his Instagram
and it's pretty amazing you know I've
noticed this thing about we were
watching this incredible YouTube video
about these Indian scammers and this guy
this hacker like infiltrated their whole
system and he was showing his Facebook
page and it was just like soul flows
they're like these scammers that they
present themselves as these incredible
genius entrepreneurs alright there's
these incredible businessman young
successful well-traveled well-dressed
you know it's really easy to make money
when you're scamming people stealing
stealing their money right so here's so
flow here he is if you didn't know
anything about him you just think like
man this guy's young and successful he's
traveled he's blimp
he's an entrepreneur man was this guy
doing he figured it out this is my
favorite one here he is with like a
really nice watch on his phone doing
business there's a man doing business
right here he goes please read I
recently decided to reflect on my past I
wanted to remember exactly how it felt
in the last five years I remembered how
thankful I used to be how excited I was
the first time I made 500 dollars in a
month at 14 years old then 1,000 a day
at 18 eventually a hundred thousand he
goes in revenue he's a not to be
mistaken with profit
revenue and profit is kind the same
thing when you're scanning people
there's no overhead gap yeah I don't
think you want to [ __ ] with the IRS but
who knows you know he's not in America
he bounced he's in South Korea we'll get
to that eventually a hundred thousand
dollars a day at 21 I'm getting tylo Pez
vibes from him somewhere along the way I
felt victim to fake and martyrius dick
lifestyle bro look at you look what this
photo is of Instagram is all about
showing content that will retain users
on the app longest the problem is that
the content we want to see is not the
content we need to see in order to
better ourselves and become the best
version of ourselves there's no
connection to this and the paragraph
above just to point that out
well that I don't go to Instagram to
better myself that isn't actually my
goal when I open up the answer that is
nobody's goal right now no that's a
great a good point for that reason I
don't feel like the content I post on
Instagram has been a good
personification I don't think that word
makes sense there you can't either
that's not what personification is has
been a good personification of Who I am
and aspire to be so many of us men oh
are caught up and showing off money and
cars while many women are showing off
their bodies you don't have to we do
this because society rewards people are
having these things rather than
rewarding the hard work there's endless
amounts of this content which is more or
less people posting their trophies or
accomplishments I feel like society has
become all about the trophies and less
about the work I'm tired of being
consumed of it I'm proud of my business
and fitness program progress but also
feel like I'm flexing my posting about
it once you change my content and focus
on showing the hustle and love for life
there are so many talented minds out
there and it's
a dream that they need what they need is
to be grounded by reality and
authenticity
therefore my goal is to post content
that provides value to those who follow
me rather than just post content to make
me look good
posting content just to show off is
selfish who [ __ ] cares you have a
Lambo cool you have a big butt
cool let's post content on Instagram
that brings us all closer together
enough with the [ __ ] that I'm so
embarrassed he continued after that to
post his regular [ __ ] by the way so so
that's when he said let's let's make a
change right and so the next post is him
in Korea visiting Shanghai was nice but
to see the effect of coronavirus is
truly sad oh yeah you're really sad by
it nice business opportunity by the way
too so let's see here he is this is
definitely photoshopped to it right his
skin
he said oh and by the way he tagged that
he says ritz-carlton Tokyo like broad
did you really have to tag there at the
ritz-carlton trying to adopt the Korean
style though I took this photo in Tokyo
sorry if my selfie game needs work love
you guys and then hear this one he goes
looking down on all my enemies I'm so
far up I'll never go down I've worked so
hard to make it to the sky I think
they're all stupid captions going into
an elevator and capturing OCO photo
doesn't make you an achiever on
Instagram we consume endless content
that isn't helpful to us it's just a
huge distraction everybody wants to
capture our attention the unfortunate
part is that not everyone that does is
giving you value so much value here on
this page so when someone posts a
meaningless caption like it's just dumb
he's really smart you could tell they
haven't achieved anything they're
fooling people into idolizing someone
who can take nice photos and tell a cute
story
now this is when it gets really fun is
after all of that
these are his Instagram stories from
last
just one night and he's been posting
this [ __ ] all the time this is just from
one night by the way are we gonna get
claim for this music it didn't okay I
uploaded it sag like that link is it
YouTube ok great it didn't get claim so
so sit back and joy a night and so flow
on Instagram house it's not gonna get
claimed here I'm just gonna mute it you
don't need to sound ok Hardy so yeah
here he is showing that he's in the VIP
section of the club by the way no
coronavirus nobody's even where he's
going on I guess South Korea's on top of
their [ __ ] so safe there's no place in
the world party like Korea even more so
during these times love Korea's so much
they're sharing a bottle he's got in his
bottle in his hand like a really
expensive bottle of Dom Perignon and
here he's got Don Perry on Rose a which
is really rare hard to get very
expensive and gather sharing wait I am
confused by their [ __ ] so he's up on the
DJ booth sharing Dave
there are masks are down and they're
sharing ha yeah that doesn't seem good
he's behind the DJ booth anyway I can
see that he's definitely taken as an
advice to heart here's here's comments
on his social page is this on the
Thunder labs Facebook page or what there
was a ton of comments on yes on the I
order two lights from your so-called
business and haven't heard back from you
I will get everyone to report your
account to the police piece-of-shit
scammer you deserves to be hung in the
streets Wow can you send me my [ __ ] that
I paid you for so he's got all kinds of
her I ordered the nebulize and I've not
received it in six weeks please give me
a refund yeah just a lot of comments
like this well you will you reply to my
email please when we send me my pet bed
but they are saying thunder
laughs by name so just proof that it is
connected it is evidence it's evidence
no I know you want to hedge the bets
just so you know Oh anyone to worry
about him suing us or anything
III also wondered I wonder if he comes
back from South Korea if there's gonna
be a we should invite him on the podcast
and see what the FBI waiting for here's
more comments bunch of thieves take your
money and then stop replying don't buy
for this company they're scammers could
you please tell me where in my package
will arrive bought it on the in December
and they shouldn't be ignoring my emails
Facebook needs to take these people off
I totally agree order because I saw them
on Facebook advertise I just heard that
YouTube was putting like six and a half
million dollars into fighting fake
misinformation on YouTube and removing
stuff like that and you never see
Facebook do anything I have to say a lot
of people complain about YouTube but I
always say if you compare YouTube to
Facebook yeah it's just I don't even
know how Facebook operates I don't
understand it because you're not gonna
see ads for in 95 mm run fake ads for
during the pandemic like that that
should be their main focus right not to
eliminate those things and it ran for a
long time apparently you know Facebook
needs to take these people off I order
because I saw them on Facebook they
ripped me off them weren't what's for my
mind I think this is Facebook they need
the Facebook is liable for this [ __ ] man
you know I mean you could do this from
Nigeria you could do this from anywhere
just rip off all these people yeah but
the thing is just make a nice website
that looks official here's how I know
Facebook's the most crooked back [ __ ]
[ __ ] country or country website if
so flow has deep ties with them he was
like one of the first pages to monetize
I know Joey salads works with them and
has all these monetization opportunities
so he has deep ties with Facebook
meanwhile running straight up allegedly
during a pandemic pranks pranks there
was one really great one he goes he
tweets out what turns you on and then he
posts a screenshot me and it says your
appealed you appealed it a decision to
deactivate your ad account hello thanks
for reaching out we reactivated your
advertising account so they banned his
account for something and then he was
able to appeal it and get it reactivated
and then immediately started pranking
because the day is basically lines up
perfectly right December 15 yeah I mean
he got all this up and running and
selling fake masks by early February
Facebook is a [ __ ] joke they are a
joke they are scourge on this planet I
swear to god yeah now that turns me on
my girl that's how you know he's such a
dumb person bro why would you tweet out
proudly that you're you were banned from
the posting ads on Facebook also his
twitter is just hilarious in the sense
like he he's verified he has a check
mark but he only has 40,000 followers
which is pretty low but then also he
tweets get zero likes yeah that one
happened only zero that one has one life
because so flow was never personality
driven YouTube channel because he kept
stealing content about a picture so but
I feel like you know but it's his name
so it's weird
ya have 40,000 followers though and get
zero like not even a single person click
like why would you continue to tweet
even like - it makes the bags are so
relatable you know it's like being in
outer space and then talking to people
it's and he still links to Thunder labs
his Twitter account yeah that's awesome
he's actually been active as recently as
April 14th on Twitter though I think it
was April 17th seemed to be when the
took place so it is strange that he's
still posting Instagram stories though
and then this is done completely
underground like he probably should know
he's very active on Instagram but and
this is really weird if you go to his
YouTube channel so flow comedy which is
where he used to post his pranks and
stuff it now I guess this is his next
scheme he's working on crypto cake this
is a year ago this was when it was
really hot watch this video it's so
bizarre this is the only video on the
channel it's so bizarre you guys
remember discovering his I don't think
we talked about it look at this what is
this this looks like a girl who works at
a dispensary not a financial trader
sorry for judging you but isn't that not
a girl who works at a dispensary that's
every girl who works at a dispensary not
a fad alright not a fidget spinner years
ago the internet started printing life
wow that sounds legit
whenever you say printing money you have
got my attention so the creep the
morning show never took off they had one
episode I'm sure he's probably just ran
this up like as a pop up all over the
place just as a portal to to scheme
people in some way that's what I'm
assuming
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
I just found another bang orbit wheat
right here look at this guy look at it
look at this guy dude this guy's a
legend he's in a tiny shirt what I see
oh potatoes alright I'm out I'm out what
do you got then here I just put it right
below that link just look at this this
image add to story to make this viral
one like and then what the one reply
well it's a picture of him or his friend
holding up a census my ex is a [ __ ]
send dick pics - that is illegal I think
that's horrible
yeah and I'll obviously blur that phone
number wait that's that's a horrible
thing to try to make go viral why would
you encourage people to send dick pics
that's that's you're illegal and you
don't even know who you're sending it to
that is awful you think that's funny
that's horrible add this to story to
make this viral my ex is a [ __ ] send
dick pics too and then there's the
number and then underneath it says what
part of this dude do you think was funny
go back to stealing content because your
original stuff is trash so this was this
tweet has been up since May 26 7 and it
has one like yeah like to actually think
that that's something funny to go viral
he's so that's so not it reminds me you
remember still to this day one of the
funniest things that's ever been on the
show is that story he told about yeah it
was story about like yeah it was the
most humble thing that he's ever done in
his life was taken ugly girl talking
about it like even such a saint man that
[ __ ] was crazy I wonder if he'll come
back on the show talking about that is
gonna change yeah yeah this is authentic
this is making me grow as a person
well anyway that's it that is our h3
right oh wait we have more but that was
he also like recently or one of those
thunder lab accounts retweeted Mark
Cuban he's a one you know how Mark Cuban
says you're either up here Elon Musk all
the time too he's a pig he says you're
either an
Neuer or a want lunch or I'm thinking
might be so he just retweeted Mark Cuban
going when we look back in five years we
were going to realize that there were 10
to 20 amazing companies that were
started that changed the world and led
us to a brighter future ask yourself why
not me or why not us now is your time
the world is waiting suppose like yes
and Mark Cuban has been very active
about the whole pandemic and how
companies could help or what they should
do whatever he's talking about it a lot
but it's so funny that so flu would even
engage considering his form of business
he said he really sees himself as
entrepreneur which is pretty wild but I
mean this is the same guy who said sweet
dick pics to my [ __ ] ex-girlfriend and
the dude who bragged about taking an
ugly girl on a helicopter flight so the
dudes a little twisted in the head
clearly well that's it that's it for
today I keep not getting to these videos
I want to wear on the Skippy at Cannes
and the Jimmy Lee news but I feel bad so
let's wrap it up we want to say thank
you to all of our beautiful fans to the
Past to the crew - Ian - zap - Dan - ela
- all of you out there who said I'm
gonna do one of these rants like the
girl who said I've come out here I come
out here and I've entertained you all
and I and I do my best and everybody
sits here has so much fun we all laugh
we'll have such a good time because even
outside up there cuz the aliens aren't
answering us and we're destroying the
planet and my dogs don't even love me
and my dogs won't eat food and I get
worried because my dogs who need food
and I try to feed them and they keep
passing on the food while my dogs eat
the food and it keeps stressing out more
and more but even though all that it
stresses on my shoulders I come out here
to entertain you guys and goddammit if
that's not enough then why don't I just
jump off a bridge it cetera nobody's
smiling on the zoom so I think it was a
flop
any comments from peanut gallery before
we part ways Ian what are you smiling I
laughed about thank you that zach is not
enough yeah if oh come on
mob we're just saying you're just mean
Frank you you're a positive guys yeah
you would smile even if it wasn't really
funny if this if I get this from Zach
it's not it up hey you hear that it's
not enough all right thank you guys
we'll see you next week bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah Monica wrap it up